[Music]
they burnt him alive in a copper scam he
wasn't in a game he didn't do drugs
I was my only nephew mmm he was 15 years
old two years $10,000 nothing thank you
so much thank you I'm so sorry
that was from our town-hall last year
the woman I showed that hug with is
Rachelle Sykes her nephew Demetrius
Griffin was murdered by a vicious gang
and at that time no arrests have been
made after two years of investigation
and one year later have Demetrius
killers been brought to justice
joining me now is Rachelle Sykes and
Polly Sykes
demetria's mother Rachelle it is good to
see you again
nice and Rachelle I didn't meet you last
time you wouldn't be with us I know and
Polly tell us no leads in this
investigation we have no leads we need
as much help as we can to bring the
killer to justice that's why it's
important to us to keep the story out
here so we can get help all kids life
matters to me and my son was viciously
taken from me burnt alive in the garbage
and no mothers have to deal with that so
it's kinda hard for me right now
Polly there are no words Rachelle one in
six murders are solved in this city one
in six it's the lowest solve solving
murders rate in the country the worst
called clearance rate in the country how
does that how does that make everybody
here here feel it makes me feel horrible
it makes me feel that we as people don't
value life don't value children we don't
have any values anymore
dimitra's was a loving sweet kid he was
96 pounds he was 49 they burned him
beyond recognition I had to get dental
records to identify him
when we had the no service no way to say
goodbye we had to take him straight from
the morgue to the grave we had to have a
memorial service what
we keep doing and it's been three years
there hasn't been any nothing nobody
said anything nobody's turning anything
nobody's nothing we need to stop waiting
to a hit our doorstep we need to say
something if we see something all
everyone if I hear everyone's society
and the [ __ ] no snitch thing if it's
wrong report it and Polly you see a lot
of coverage of other crimes around the
United States and they're serious
whether mass shootings in other states
and other communities do you feel like
it gets the coverage here in Chicago or
other cities like it st. Louis Detroit
Oakland does it get the coverage does
this situation is this acceptable to
anyone no it's not accept anyone no I
don't like it had my coverage of it you
know like you said we need to stick
together we need to speak out you know
violence is just the worst thing ever
these are our kids and they are appoint
us thank you for being it was you almost
didn't come and we really really
appreciate it I never forgot Demetrius
not one day since last year and it's a
$15,000 reward yeah it's 20,000 now
$20,000 someone can tell us something
about this someone can tell us something
about this murder we have some time for
some questions from the audience some
points I think we're gonna go to Marlene
first Marlene I am Marlene hi everyone I
feel your pain I lost a brother to gun
got violence and what's the most
heart-wrenching thing to ever go through
oh my gosh it was but for me it's it's
not a question the statement it's just
like we need the foundation of love and
unity and peace like that we need to get
along with each other that's what it is
we need to get along and and getting
along is like back in the days when we
had the big mom
we had people looking out for each other
and that's what means the most to me my
brother was loving coyote he went to
school what the college wasn't any gang
and he just got caught in the crossfire
and he died instantly got shot in the
head and we don't he found one killer we
did and what makes us grounded and keep
us grinding exciting
we hope the legacy and our legacy is to
love one another a piece and you didn't
stop hating and I always tell people
reason why we don't like each other no
because I don't get it long when you
should care about we're gonna care about
each other
it's fellow Americans I want to go back
to the panel and thank you so much for
that panel when you've heard these two
stories two women two different tragic
stories Charlie let's go to you we lack
of a lack of love unity role models
fathers in some sense enough police
enough support for the police is a lot
it's a lot how we didn't talk about
drugs we didn't touch on drugs in this
situation but drugs have been a part of
a lot of the violence either selling
them pushing them being on them getting
on them because of this situation how
important is that it's very important
because see I always believe some of the
mothers here call a hard sell thank you
I
I've seen it when you have children who
come home with $400 sneakers on been out
all night long don't go to school they
become the head of households and a drug
kid will tell you listen why should I go
to school when I can make two or three
hundred dollars a day and come home
everything the foundation starts at home
drugs is definitely the scourge of any
community but it became an epidemic when
it started going to other communities
see it's always been here in the black
chameleon Joseph on this issue we have a
lot of pain across this country of
opioid deaths meth
now that pushes to legalize drugs legal
drug is gonna solve our problems rhonchi
mantillas violence you're seeing a lot
of terrible violence and legalized
communities where drugs are legal eyes
because they're always figuring out a
way to bring in cheaper more powerful
stuff to undercut the legal sales that's
where we are now for lack of censorship
I'll not repeat what I was thinking in
my mind but I will say this that the
it's not just opioid epidemic I mean in
one community it's an epidemic and
another that's a scourge but
particularly in our community we're
seeing the second and third generation
of crack babies we're also seeing a
large influx in the number of kids who
have learning disabilities now we don't
talk about that in terms of how people
get attracted so what brings them to the
game well a lot of them are looking for
someone to love someone to help them or
someone they accept them and that's what
you find happening and a lot of these
communities particularly ours Anthony
but there's hope here there's hope in
this room tonight there's hope the
people that came here tonight to tell
their story to share their pain and to
demand action from within ourselves and
from our leadership I want people to
know here that we have put violence on
trial in Illinois violence is on trial
in Illinois
and we are turning pain into policy pain
into policy I'm a grieving father it
don't feel good when you lose your child
it affects your whole DNA I want every
citizen in it I need everybody in
America to be very patriotic help us
pass comprehensive legislation on
violence as a human high health crisis
in the disease we will all be eliminated
from this planet if we don't get control
legislation is very key right now we
need people to walk with us to spring
for you thank you for being here panels